[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous mon histoire moi elle
commence par un coup de téléphone en
fait un coup de téléphone il y a
quelques années je décroche et j'ai le
club de l'ASSE qui m'appelle en me
disant ben voilà on va monter le premier
musée du foot en France en premier musée
de club et on a sélectionné quelques
agences dont une agence stéphanoise je
voulais pas dit mais Pierre-Yves
l'agence de scénographie et les charrons
donc on nous appelle donc on était très
contents quand vous êtes plus que trois
à concourir et à faire le projet donc la
personne commence à m'expliquer pas mal
de choses au téléphone je raccroche et
là je me rends compte que pour la
personne je suis stéphanois elle me
parle de foot donc c'est une évidence
que je spécialiste de la SS passionné
que je vais voir tous les matchs j'en
avais pas vu un seul voilà c'était pas
ni mon univers ni mon domaine mais pas
plus que si on propose une expo sur ton
temps Camon je suis spécialiste voilà de
l'archéologie d'Égypte donc je me dis il
y a quand même un petit billet parce que
si on présente ce projet en leur faisant
comprendre qu'on n'est pas passionné fou
dingue ça allait être compliqué donc
avec mon associé il se dit bon on va
rester dans l'ambiguïté donc on fait le
projet donc pardon c'était aller trop
vite on fait le projet c'est-à-dire que
nous c'est un métier on va on est
beaucoup aidé par l'informatique et la
3D on va numériser tous les toutes les
collections donc là j'ai numériser des
ballons des chaussures des maillots des
ballons des chaussures et des maillots
donc on installe toute l'histoire voilà
on soit tout le parcours
historique on fait la grande
présentation passer un oral en présence
d'une autre notre projet et la personne
en face de moi me répond à un moment oui
parce que vous comprenez dans le coop
Nord etc et là dans mon cerveau Cap Nord
je ne sais pas du tout ce que c'était en
fait donc je suis répond par une
périphrase en me disant ça devrait
passer ça passe tellement bien qu'on
gagne le projet voilà donc on gagne de
projet on a fait le musée puis on a
restauré il y a pas très longtemps et
par contre premier rendez-vous de
travail je l'ai rencontré je vous dise
un truc le foot nada c'est-à-dire que un
j'ai jamais vu le match
c'est pas trop de quoi je parle mais je
leur explique par contre justement c'est
un point de vue intéressant parce que
faire un musée de passionné par des
passionnés en gros ça fonctionne pas
parce qu'il faut un élément de médiation
c'est à dire que si j'accumulais 400 000
maillots parce qu'ils ont été portés sur
toute l'histoire de la SS au bout du
quatrième anneau même si vous êtes
passionné voilà vous allez vous lassez
et passer à autre chose donc ils ont
conviennent il y a quand même un petit
moment on va dire de flottement vous
connaissez le président du club à
l'époque remis autant dire que il y a eu
un très grand moment de flottement même
donc on commence à travailler ça se
passe plutôt bien sont des gens qui sont
passionnés donc c'est toujours
intéressant de travailler avec les
passionné l'équipe est très sympa en
interne on conçoit donc tout notre musée
en 3D on commence à avoir les
entreprises on va attaquer les travaux
et puis d'un seul coup autre coup du fil
encore un coup de téléphone à qui arrive
ouais ça va bien oui ça va bien j'ai
comme il s'appelle Djokovic qui m'a
appelé il donne sa voiture oui donc sa
voiture bah très bien non vous avez pas
compris donc sa voiture mais il la
venons le musée donc si vous voulez
qu'on me rajoute un ballon ou un
une vraie voiture ça devenait compliqué
donc je bâton touche ah il est au
premier étage il y a des escaliers en
disant c'est bon il prend pas la mettre
ah bah c'est pas grave on démontre le
mur et on la passera dans le mur donc la
grande moment de blanc et puis autre
autre problématique c'est qu'est-ce que
dit cette voiture en fait c'est la
voiture qui s'est acheté avec les
cachets qu'il a fallait cacher avec
l'argent qu'il a pu gagner grâce au
grâce au moment célèbre de de ce club là
mais elle disait rien d'autre donc on a
réussi à se débrouiller pour l'intégrer
dans les collections et vu que c'est
quelque chose de très important vous
allez la photo on a démonté le mur et on
a rentré la voiture du curcovie qui fait
partie maintenant des collections tout
ça pour vous dire qu'on a beaucoup
prévoir en 3D
border les choses chaque fois dans la
vraie vie mais il arrive un événement
qui fait qu'il va falloir s'adapter et
surtout comprendre son interlocuteur
parce que très honnêtement si on était
vraiment
muséographe stricto-sensus la voiture
n'avait pas de sens d'autres voitures du
sens dans cette collection mais passer
là il n'empêche qu'elle était voilà
d'abord c'était donner enfin c'est un
élément important de la vie de cette
histoire là et donc il a fallu aussi
qu'on concilie notre intégrité entre
guillemets des très gros mots tu es très
gros guillemets parce que c'est pas très
intègre ou pas avec le fait d'intégrer
ce véhicule là
donc asse voilà plutôt plutôt sympa avec
j'avais l'impression de faire un musée
d'art sacré on est triste sur un musée
de sacré pas très longtemps avant
honnêtement j'ai jamais vu enfin des
gens sont rentrés quand on ouvert le
musée le 1er jour il y avait la queue et
il y a quelqu'un qui s'est effondré en
larmes devant la tenue de Galtier on
avait un défilé de tenue et là je me
suis rendu compte que j'avais fait mais
c'était content parce que on se balade
toujours les premiers jours dans le
musée incognito pendant un petit peu ce
que fait le public ce qui comprend ce
qu'il aime ce qu'il aime pas et
franchement bah ça m'a fait quelque
chose ça va une personne pour qui
c'était vraiment hyper important d'être
là et d'avoir pu cet élément là
mon premier voilà première rencontre
alors c'est un travail de longue haleine
c'est un travail d'un an un an et demi
donc on va passer avec les gens on va
les aimer on va les détester et après on
va absolument voir du jour au lendemain
le musée est parti le fini puis nous on
passe à autre chose alors autre chose
pareil rencontre pardon up c'est voilà
c'est autre rencontre alors c'est pas un
coup de fil c'est un salon professionnel
il y a une petite dame qui passe nous
voir sur un salon qui nous dit ah j'ai
un super projet sans dinde dans tout de
suite on se met arrivé se dit waouh
c'est génial on va te choper un projet
en Inde si on a c'est dans le Ladak pas
trop entendu parler ça capte d'altitude
ça la frontière entre la Chine le
Pakistan et l'Inde non on se dit waouh
ça va pas falloir passer la frontière
d'un côté ou l'autre sinon on va jamais
nous revoir donc on accepte mais nous
dit par contre c'est une oMG qui
travaille sur place avec un projet qu'on
a trouvé hyper intéressant je suis pas
l'air d'un sacré tout à l'heure à cette
altitude là il y a pas d'humidité il
fait froid toute l'année donc les
collections sont très très bien
conservées c'est avec des papiers du
Moyen-Âge chez nous qui seraient
dégradés chez eux ils sont neuf et coup
de chance il construisent un stade à
côté il creuse et ils tombent sur des
collections qui remettaient à mon cause
l'arrivée de l'influence du bouddhisme
dans cette région là sauf que ces
papiers ont une importance historique
énorme pour l'Inde donc le musée de
délit dit est on ramène à délit ses
collections là normale mais c'est
nationsnales et sur place les moines non
c'est les textes sacrés donc sacrés il
reste monastère et négocie et en fait la
négociation ça a été de dire ben on fait
le musée dans le monastère c'est-à-dire
qu'on va protéger ses collections elles
sont bien étudiées elles sont bien
conservées mais elles restent sacrée et
donc là on se retrouve en nous disant
toute manière on n'a pas beaucoup de
moyens les conditions de vie sont dures
ce qu'on vous propose c'est de faire une
opération commando on vous emmène
pendant 15 jours une situe et vous
faites tout le musée en 15 jours donc on
est parti avec nos ordi un peu mal
préparé je voulais vous ré parce que
quand la porte de l'Alliance s'ouvre à
4000 mètres d'altitude il n'y a pas
d'oxygène votre cœur il Bala chaman et
sauf qu'il s'arrête jamais de batacher à
MAD parce que vous êtes en manque
d'oxygène enfin bon on s'adapte on fait
le musée et là rencontre une rencontre
culturelle encore bien plus forte que le
foot un autre monde le poteau que vous
avez au milieu il faut toujours le
contourner par la gauche donc en fait
quand vous arrivez on vous donne plein
de petits réflexes comme ça comme vous
allez pas vous promener tout dans une
église en fait pour eux c'est hyper
important de tourner toujours autour du
poteau par la gauche en plein de petits
réflexes et surtout culturellement vous
voulez pas que ce soit un musée
d'occidentaux posé en fait dans un
endroit vous savez aucun sens donc on a
énormément discuté avec vous avec eux de
façon complexe pour arriver à comprendre
et on discutant ils ont fait admettre
parce qu'au départ on était un petit peu
les gens qui venaient de loin donner des
leçons à l'usure et qui repartait
c'était un petit peu étrange comme
relation je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'on travaille d'habitude un an et demi
avec les gens pour aboutir à une
exposition amuser et donc on a les
images sont pas terribles s'intéresse
sur place du coup on a adopté leur
culture c'est-à-dire qu'on a les
collections qui sont qui sont ici qui
sont les vrais impressions etc et on a
repris la typologie de la toile imprimée
avec plein plein de couleurs vous
imaginez c'est très très qui permettait
et ça c'était assez rapidement accepté
en se disant oui il y avait une
typologie locale même s'il était fait
par des Occidentaux qui ne comprenaient
rien assez de culture culturelle donc là
aussi des échanges hyper touchants avec
la barrière de la langue on se comprend
mais la voyant la culture on se comprend
vraiment pas mais des échanges des
petits moments comme ça suspendus dans
le temps très très très intéressant
juste une petite anecdote c'est qu'on
s'est rendu compte que les moines ont
tellement l'habitude du froid et du
manque d'humilité ce n'est pas chauffé
donc il nous invitait à manger dans le
réfectoire autant vous dire que dehors
il fait très très chaud et on a fini par
aller manger avec la cuisinière c'était
le seul endroit il y avait avec le
réchaud on avait un petit peu pour
occidentaux de la chaleur
donc là voilà
j'allais dire choc un petit peu à
culturel et d'échanges mais hyper
enrichissant comme un autre métier on
est toujours dans la découverte d'autres
mondes route coup de fil de téléphone
avec une liaison très mauvaise au
téléphone vous savez vous décrocher la
liaison est mauvaise et dans votre tête
vous dit ouh là là il va me vendre une
box ou un téléphone ou un forfait je
sais pas quoi donc à moitié aimable et
donc la personne commence à me parler et
me dire voilà je me suis dit j'ai pas de
temps en fait je commence à couper j'ai
autre chose à et la personne me
dit ah mais je représente le
gouvernement de sultanat de Man on va
construire un musée donc là j'ai changé
de ton et
d'éléments et donc on a fini voilà par
découvrir ce cet endroit que je ne
connaissais pas
Oman et aller travailler là-bas là aussi
choc culturel beaucoup moins important
civilisation on va dire arabo musulmane
donc on la connaît il y a eu plein plein
d'échanges donc on est dans un univers
qu'on connaît plus par contre assez
compliqué en termes d'incompréhension
alors préhension culturelle on le
premier musée historique et en fait on a
trouvé des textes d'auteurs du monde
entier qui sont passés dans la capitale
de Mascate depuis l'an 700 et quelques
aujourd'hui qui décrivent cette capitale
et laquelle se façon pertinente parce
que quand on y est on a l'impression que
la description était fait à 15 jours la
fois sur les gens et à la fois sur la
sur la beauté des lieux donc on leur dit
ben on va projeter les fantômes le front
home d'un cartographe Perse qui est
passé en 300 et quelques 704 le fantôme
d'un père voilà qui vont être projeté
sur le mur et on aura dans la longue
d'origine la description puis ça sera
très lui dessous en anglais en arabe
dessous et donc le traducteur traduit
parce qu'on passait par l'anglais mais
qui était pas très bon donc il traduit
en arabe il traduit fantôme par Jim or
un Jim ça n'a pas d'existence physique
c'est un esprit mais qui est
complètement immatériel comme une sorte
de Saint-Esprit ce préféré ils sont fait
l'analogie donc ils comprenait pas qu'on
puisse projeter sur un mur quelque chose
qui n'a pas de matérialité et nous on
comprenait pas qui comprenait pas qu'on
projetait un fantôme sur un mur on se
mettait à dessiner un fantôme blanc
enfin pour nous ça faisait aucun souci
et comme ça pas mal d'échanges
d'incompréhension pourquoi ils veulent
pas atteindre vraiment ils veulent pas
faire le truc quoi et eux les amis ils
sont complètement crétins ils prennent
un truc qui n'existe pas et on a fini
par comprendre que en fait le mot était
pas le bon donc on le finit par dire que
c'est des personnages et tout le monde a
dit bah ok ça match on part bon fini
notre premier musée là-bas c'est un tout
petit monde donc ça marche plutôt bien
un petit musée premier musée qui était
refait donc c'était assez facile et on
nous confie un autre musée en nous
disant ben en fait l'éducation nationale
elle avait à peine 30 ans à Oman elle
est stable depuis 30 ans donc on va
faire un musée pour expliquer aux gens
comment on apprend à apprendre à la fois
amuser
identifier en fait pour les profs qui
vont venir là et pour les élèves qui
vont venir aussi voir comment le super
sultan en 30 ans a réussi à développer
une des écoles etc donc on pouvait
l'enjeu assez intéressant mais on leur
dit par contre il y a un petit biais
c'est-à-dire si je suis prof que je
viens faut pas que je trouve le même
niveau d'information que si j'ai 10 ans
et quelqu'un visait le musée sinon je
vais pas m'intéresser enfin même pas me
parler de sciences de l'éducation à un
enfant donc on me dit pas de souci donc
nous on leur dit bah voilà le niveau
s'adaptera sur les daltectives sur les
films sur le contenu du musée on
travaille un an on avance plein de
péripéties le bâtiment sort de terre on
construit et puis c'est un mois
d'ouverture il y a le client qui vient
qui me dit Pierre-Yves ils sont les
écrans qui montent et qui descendent
on va me chercher le contrat c'est des
gens qui sont très très contrats à
l'anglo-saxonne c'est-à-dire toutes les
marqué tout est inscrit quatre fois mais
regardez là il y a marqué que le niveau
culturel ça montrait ça descendra non
mais c'est le niveau culturel c'est à
dire que la dalle vous pourrez appeler
effectivement pour un enfant mais vu que
c'était marqué dans le contrat
impossible de s'en sortir donc en fait
c'est leur art musée où j'ai fait vous
pouvez prendre l'écran et le monter au
lieu descendre alors le contenu s'adapte
mais physiquement on est obligé de
lâcher parce qu'ils ont l'impression
qu'on était en train de se croquer enfin
ça a vraiment tourné
j'ai l'impression qu'on est en train de
de magouiller pour pas payer ce qu'on
avait réellement réellement vendu
troisième type d'exemple à Oman mais là
qui est presque un contre exemple on a
créé pour les Archives nationales et ils
ont des objets qui sont d'une beauté et
dans un lieu qui était d'un romantisme
avec des vieux ouvrages des rouleaux des
de la calligraphie à tomber par terre et
donc on leur a proposé un musée qui pour
nous était pas une sorte de bibliothèque
géante un lieu avec une âme un lieu avec
[Musique]
c'est la moitié des gens mais c'est pas
grave là où le parachutiste s'est
accroché dans dans la l'église et donc
on travaille là-bas et on arrive il y a
ça c'est-à-dire aliments de mannequin
avec je ne sais pas combien d'une forme
là vous en avez ça doit faire 800 mètres
carrés donc vous imaginez on a tout le
tour tout le centre partout partout et
donc on tombe sur responsable du musée
qui est très content parce que en gros
il a la plus grosse collection de voilà
de d'éléments
de la deuxième guerre mondiale à cet
endroit là etc etc et donc nous on
commence à négocier en expliquant après
c'est toujours assez intéressant parce
que c'est des gens passionné qui
accumulent mais qui à la fois vu
s'ouvrir au grand public et c'est là où
on a notre rôle nous deux médiation de
dire oui une collection comme ça c'est
bien pour le spécialiste par contre sous
la tiré du grand public elle fait
arriver il y a un sacré gap donc on a
réussi alors imposer ça pardon imposer
c'est vraiment un mot que je choisis
c'est le même musée même endroit même
lieu avec la l'avion qui est au milieu
et en fait le clin d'oeil en fait vu que
tout avait été parachuté on a pas
rajouté les vitrines donc là aussi de
grandes discussions techniques avec les
gens qui font les vitrines pour les
avoir complètement désaxé qu'on ait
l'impression qu'elle flotte qu'il soit
pas suspendue elles sont pas bien
évidemment et des problèmes de
conservation il faut que les costumes à
l'intérieur soient une hygrométrie
constante soit avec peu de lumière enfin
tout ce qu'on peut connaître dans nos
métiers donc l'avion donc ça c'est acté
on finit par adopter notre mode de
pensée on va dire
et puis l'avion l'avion au milieu et là
nous on se rend compte que l'avion il
est un numéro comme tous les avions il a
un numéro sur le côté et ils nous disent
c'est génial parce que cet avion c'est
l'avion qui 7000 là est passé en haut et
les parachutistes qu'on est l'histoire
ils sont tombés c'est vrai ils sont
tombés cet avion là voilà et puis les
recherches avancent parce que on a un
petit peu on aime bien rencontrer les
spécialistes avec eux donc on leur
demande le mec il nous dit on a un
problème c'est qu'on a trouvé des
numéros dans l'avion ça correspond pas
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait cet avion a été
repeint aux États-Unis comme le numéro
pas moyen de savoir si c'est mon avion
il monte dans le poste de pilotage il
glisse sa main il sort une pièce dans un
pays qui était sa pièce porte chance
qu'il avait glissé dedans c'est celui-là
ensuite il a été 10000 et on lui a donné
d'autres avions vous savez ce n'était
pas pilote d'un avion ça a changé tout
le temps après il est parti en Hollande
et la pièce ne veut jamais tombée c'est
à dire que cet avion après une avion
civile enfin personne avec glissé la
main pour aller chercher la pièce et
donc évidemment on a la pièce évidemment
on a fait une pièce dédiée à ça enfin
nous un endroit dédié à ça pour raconter
cette belle histoire de rencontre et de
qui nous a fait qui nous a fait arriver
par contre là on s'est beaucoup alors
c'est un petit peu un combat de
spécialiste mais on voulait absolument
justement quand on a eu toutes ces
histoires ne pas être un musée qui
raconte une histoire générale mais je
sais qu'il raconte l'histoire humaine
ils ont ils en ont plein et donc en fait
on a demandé on a voulu puis ça a été
accepté qu'on personnalise c'est à dire
que chaque thématique chaque panneau il
y a un mannequin qui est hyper réaliste
et un comédien qu'on a numérisé ensuite
qui a été sculpté et en fait on a une
graduation parce que c'est les
militaires ils aiment bien la tenue la
vraie tenue avec le mannequin hyper
réaliste et on a réussi à imposer de
rester blanc voilà ou aluminium quand
c'est des personnages qui ont réellement
existé et dont le portrait était refait
mais on a dû lâcher
pour leur fameuse scène où les troupes
montagnes dans l'avion qui était un
petit peu la leur dada donc là je peux
le résume mais c'est un an et demi de
discussion disons tous les mannequins
sont blancs non veineux machin non et on
explique pourquoi et on explique ce
qu'on veut dire avec un mannequin blanc
on explique ce qu'on veut dire avec un
mannequin qui en tirage en sculpture en
alu et puis avec une restitution
à cet endroit là je suis en train de
passer le temps donc je vais arrêter je
savais juste une autre une autre petite
une petite conclus enfin pas conclusion
mais un autre petit élément souvent
aujourd'hui on entend parler pas mal de
nouvelles technologies et en fait on
arrive à un monde à l'envers c'est à
dire que jusqu'à maintenant on concevait
des musées avec des conservateurs qui me
disaient voilà ce que j'ai à dire donc
il nous remettait un document épais
comme ça donc nous on le disait
vous comprenez on discutait avec eux et
de ce contenu en faisant un musée et on
arrive c'est aussi à une inversion ou en
fait on a des élus ou des gens qui
arrivent qui nous disent j'ai vu ça il y
avait une grande projection j'ai vu ça
il y avait un hologramme j'ai vu ça il
me faut un hologramme dans mon musée il
me faut un truc mais qui ne savent pas
quel contenu ils ont diffuser c'est à
dire qu'on est complètement à l'envers
le moyen a remplacer en fait le fond et
le sens bah vraiment pour garder tout le
temps le fond et ne pas se faire avoir
par un effet d'annonce en disant on a le
plus grand écran on a le plus beau écran
enfin les plus bocals seraient lutter on
a plus d'eau
voilà vous avez compris c'est un métier
passion j'aurais pu durer quatre heures
mais je vais m'arrêter là et vous
remercier
[Applaudissements]